The reason our image is
not showing up immediately
has to do with the fact that our code
is being executed in the background.
Now, I know what you may be thinking,
what's the background?
Why's our code there, and
how does this affect my app?
Don't panic.
Without getting into the details,
we're going to use a method
that fixes this problem.
The method we'll use will take any
updates that we're making to the UI,
like displaying our image, and
then run them in the foreground, or
the main executing environment.
Let's see this now.
Back in our project,
we've been provided with a special
function called performUIUpdatesOnMain.
This function is defined on
the GCDBlackBox Swift file.
Now the reason we use the term blackbox
in the name of that Swift file
is because a blackbox refers to
something you can use without
knowing the internal details.
So for the purposes of this course,
you can use the function to
performUIUpdatesOnMain without
knowing how it's implemented.
You should just call this function
anytime you need to make updates to
the UI inside of the completion
handler of a network task.
Now, looking at this method,
we can see that it takes a closure
that has no parameters, and
returns void or nothing.
And since the closure
is the only parameter,
we can use the trailing closure syntax.
All we need to do is just
relocate any code responsible for
updating the UI, and
place it inside this closure.
So in our case it's just
this line of code here.
Now let's run the project.
Nice, there we go.
That's what we want.